so what have you been watching lately I
basically just watch YouTube who are
some of your favorite YouTubers oh
I knew this would think of YouTu any
YouTubers just think of any YouTubers at
all no too obscure definitely not I was
going to think I'm a freak just
recommend something that's mainstream
but not too mainstream just think of
something that normal people would watch
have you ever heard of random idiot he
has like 12 million subscribers come on
think who's someone he would know are
you familiar with the work of Zumer Paul
bunan he has 300 million subscribers
this is going terribly maybe I should
just say who I really watch I'll just
put all my cards on the table do you
know man carrying thing doesn't
everybody I've been subscribed to him
for 20 years he's beloved by all his
channel is the new mono
culture this could happen